look during the pandemic it was hard to  sometimes feel free to find a bathroom  like i live in l.a they hate to tell  your listeners just so you're making me  i occasionally would bring a cop and  have to pee in the car and i got very  comfortable with it i heard a myth a  famous actor had a van with a like  canister mechanism astronaut style if  you will  yeah they would relieve themselves in  said such canister i don't know if it's  true it's a total urban legend i will  admit something to you i haven't told  you yet casey are you ready okay yeah  okay so i had an emergency one time in  my minivan and i was really stuck in  like real bad traffic there's no exit in  your future traffic yeah you're here so  i tried it it was extremely successful  and i was like this could work